Makes Sense,
but when you look at huge stretches of time,
it's almost impossible to wrap your head around things.
So let's start small with minutes,
hours,
days.
You probably spent the last 24 hours mostly sleeping and working and you
probably wasted a good chunk of yesterday on the Internet.
Days become weeks,
weeks become months and that we have a year.
Let's look at 2017 France started to train eagles to hunt terrorists,
drones,
a check nuclear power plant held a bikini contest to pick their new intern and
people on the Internet made a challenge out of eating bleach.
You know,
the usual stuff.
Let's go back further.
A kid born in the first year of the 21st century is 18 years old now,
but the century is still young,
even if you're not.
It was largely shaped by the attacks on nine 11 which led to the war in
Afghanistan and the invasion of Iraq in March,
2011 the Syrian civil war began and is still ongoing after seven years.
Most of us were born in the 20th century,
which had the two most devastating wars in human history.
And the Cold War.
For the first time ever,
we could destroy ourselves with a nuclear weapons and we always did,
but we also had a space race and Nafta for the first time.
The incident was also invented,
which led to memes,
but also to Facebook and Twitter.
So all in all,
we're not sure if this was a good development.
The average human lives about 79 years,
which covers a good chunk of recent history.
The oldest living person on earth as currently Seleno Hannah Mitchell,
who was born in 1896 which means that his birth was closer to Napoleon ruling
Europe than to the current day.
Only 250 years ago,
the industrial revolution turn the world into a progress machine for farmers
became workers and knowledge became easier to distribute.
Around this time we started the progress that is causing climate change today,
not that long ago.
Actually,
the theory of evolution changed how we saw ourselves and the world we live in.
Newton wrote down his theory of gravity.
We discovered distant stars and very close bacteria,
the 15th century with very eventful Columbus's discovery of America and the fall
of Constantinople.
Mark,
the end of the Middle Ages wall was all the rage in the Middle Ages,
but the number one killer was disease.
The black plague killed every third European in just six years.
Around 2000 years ago,
we set the arbitrary year one of our Canada that most of the world follows
today,
but to a Roman,
the world was already ancient.
The Great Pyramids were 4,500 years ago,
so two a Roman.
The pyramids were older than the Romans are to us today.
So long ago that there was still begging mammoths on earth.
A lot of history happened before that.
Even around 7,000 years ago,
humans began writing things down.
About 12,000 years ago,
human organization exploded.
We built our first temple and around the world,
mankind began farming,
which enabled the rise of larger communities.
Our dominance over planet earth really begins here.
Homo Sapien Sapiens,
the modern human evolved at least 200,000 years ago,
50,000 years ago.
The cognitive revolution expanded our minds and innovation back then we shared
earth with at least five other human species.
The dye that died out or were killed by us
that these 2 million years ago,
Aaron says,
is already had control over fire and constructed tools from wood and stone and 6
million years ago,
the last common ancestors of chimpanzees and humans existed.
So this graph is all of human history.
Our close relative homo erectus survived a 10 times longer than we have existed.
This tiny part is the human error.
We have to zoom in a lot to even see your lifetime still.
All of human history is not that long.
65 million years ago,
the age of the dinosaurs and did an in an enormous explosion.
The dinosaurs ruled the earth for over 165 million years,
27 times.
As long as it all humans that's so long that it means a t rex that lived at 65
million years ago is closer to us today than two alive stegosaurus
dinosaurs in the form of mighty chickens are still around today
and all life on this kinase started to 600 million years ago.
The earliest animals were fish and other small,
simple sea creatures that came,
insects that reptiles and finally around 200 million years ago,
mammals join the party.
Life itself began much further back.
There is evidence that it appeared up to 4.1 billion years ago for at least at
3.5 billion years.
Life consisted only of single celled organisms.
4.5 billion years ago.
The son was born from a gigantic imploding gas cloud,
60 million years later.
Earth fault in those early years,
frequent bombardment by comets and asteroids supplied the earth with large
oceans.
But as far as the whole universe goes,
how soda system is pretty new.
13.7 5 billion years ago,
the universe was born and about half a billion years later,
our own got x.
He phoned from billions of stars,
but what came before the Big Bang?
The truth is we don't know and maybe we never will,
and there you have it.
The past.
Now let's take a look at what we know about the future.
In roughly 1 billion years,
the sun will be so hot that life on earth becomes impossible.
The death of the son,
4 billion years later marks the end of life in the solar system.
If we want to have a chance to survive,
we need to have ventured to the stars and what happens after that?
In the next 100 billion years,
most of the bigger stars around will die.
The universe becomes dimmer and dimmer illuminated only by smaller red and white
dwarfs,
but they too will eventually burn out and one day the last star in the universe
will die.
The universe will turn dark and at some point even black holes will evaporate
and dying.
When they do,
our universe will reach its final stage heat death.
Nothing changes anymore.
The Universe is dead forever.
Now you'll feeling some pretty weird fittings right now,
aren't you?
We are too.
It's only natural.
The good news is this is all far,
far away.
The only time that actually matters is now that cute girl or boy you like ask
them out.
Time is precious.
Make it count.
One of the questions we get asked the most is how we make animated videos.
The short answer is with Adobe after effects and years of training,
but if you'd like to get a glimpse,
we now have something for you.
We made skillshare tutorials explaining in detail how we animate scenes from our
videos.
If you aren't already familiar with this,
skillshare is an online learning community with more than 18,000 classes and
things like writing animation and video editing.
Their premium membership gives you unlimited access to high.
He called us he classes from professionals working in their fields so you can
improve your skills,
unlock new opportunities and do work that you really enjoy.
It's also extremely affordable.
The annual subscription is less than $10 a month.
The first 1000 people to sign up get their first two months for only 99 cents.
So if you want to learn new things and support courts cause angst,
give it a try.
How did you like this remake?
We're thinking about redoing a few of our older videos in the next one or two
years.
Any videos you would like to see redone.